Game engines are not really libraries.
They're more properly
classified as frameworks.
And frameworks have this important
concept of inversion of control.
When you're using libraries,
you've got your code that
is doing most of the work.
However, you have a couple of places
where you're going to need some help.
So you plug in a couple different
libraries, your code's running along.
You call into one of the libraries for
help with something specific,
like drawing or playing a sound.
And then your code resumes control and
keeps doing what it's doing.
On the other hand,
when you're using a framework,
the framework is doing most of the work.
And then has one particular place
where you insert your code.
So, the framework is going along,
allocating resources,
determining when things get called.
And then, eventually, when it's time for
your application-specific logic,
the framework calls into your
code to do something and then,
your code returns control
back to the framework.
This is called inversion of control.
Or, more colloquially,
The Hollywood Principle.
>> Fantastic audition, kid.
You're a real talent,
you're going to be a star, so
I'll call you when we gotta roll.
No, no, you don't call us, we call you.
>> For instance, the game engine
handles stuff like starting up the app,
setting up a place to draw,
allocating various resources.
And then only when it's finally time to
draw a frame of the game, then it calls
your code to provide the game specific
logic needed to draw that frame.
When you're done drawing, you return
control back to the framework.